no matter what are the movies or TV
shows mark hamill makes he will always
be synonymous with one role Luke
Skywalker fascist bound to happen when
an actor's breakout gig turns out to be
the lead role in the original Star Wars
films Star Wars fans loved Hamill for
being a part of their favorite movies
but he's also one of the most
accomplished voice actors in Hollywood
so Brad in addition to bringing dozens
of characters to life
Hummel is also a funny and fun-loving
guy these bloopers from behind the
scenes of his films prove it's training
day when Star Wars first came along
nobody had ever seen anything like it
including the cast and crew with all
kinds of ridiculous costumes and sci-fi
props to work with things tended to get
a little silly on set well and they only
got worse when they started playing
around with lightsabers while we've had
the luxury of decades to make fun of
lightsabers Mark Hamill and director
George Lucas had to create those iconic
moves from scratch it certainly never
waved a laser sword around before so the
process of him learning how to do its in
his outtakes makes him look very uncool
but it still packs a lot of charm super
what Star Wars is a science-fiction
movie set in space with lots of ships
star bases and alien races which means
it's loaded up with lots of made-up
jargon as Luke Skywalker
Mark Hamill certainly got his fair share
of mumbo-jumbo mouthfuls basically from
the beginning to pick up some power
converters that's in the medium range of
difficult slang but in this blooper from
Star Wars Hamill has a hard time getting
down a simple line that's laced with
just one space word not good some
distance before that thing goes look now
it's good some distance before that
thing goes supernova how do you
pronounce supernova with inflection
supernova supernova no lines no problem
in 1994 Mark Hamill took a break from
his usual roles to star in the space
simulator game Wing Commander 3 heart of
the tiger the game was one of the first
to make for use of the been cutting-edge
technology a full motion video which put
Hamill front and center in most of the
cutscenes
your ma ship touch Wing Commander three
featured over two hours of that kind of
thing which meant a lot of time in front
of the camera for the actors considering
the nature of the project it's no
surprise that things could get a little
out of hand to his credits Hamill was a
consummate professional throughout the
whole thing even when he couldn't
remember his lines we've got to be on
our guard I don't know my line but I
want everyone to think we do
Bailey scripted Mark Hamill also shows
up from time to time and interesting
indie movies such as Briggs bbear a dark
comedy about the strangest and most
mysterious Kitty TV show possible
co-written and starring Saturday Night
Live's Kyle Mooney Hamill plays Ted the
father figure of Muniz character and
also an evil human face Sun God on the
show within a movie
frigg's Bieber adventures Hamill is
barely recognizable in the parts however
his voice and sense of humor are
immediately familiar when he starts
riffing funny things to say calm down
bro you're being Hello weird
[Music]